donc je m'appelle si ségolène veut tout
moore je cuis quatre viennent personnes
handicapées de naissance en fait j'ai
manqué d'oxygène à manosque et ta fille
de deux médecins
voulaient à tout prix me faire vivre du
chu de réanimation donc 40 avait de
l'animation pour un cerveau c'est énorme
et après j'ai le frac midi vers nation
et ensuite ma vie commence à démarrer et
petit à petit on a découvert les
séquelles du manque de clients
j'adore une future présidence de la
future présidente qui est un bus
découvert une personne handicapée est
pas rare qu'un bon bout de
l'établissement public vraiment action
en fauteuil chocques nous avions besoin
de demander d'être pour ce mois au
propriétaire ou à la 5e place je pense
que vaut pas moins d'être au déjà tous
que voir et bethioua briques qui devient
assassin peut aider à rentrer aux
puits après oui au pétrole contient en
tout cas les cachots elle dit handicapé
du tout moi et chez wacom bien mal et en
protège libéral je n'ai droit à rien ce
que jérôme les découpes qui coûte donc
moi j'ai géré obama